consider a rod of mass m and suppose I
apply a force to this rod let's say
of course like that so we know that as a
result of that applied force the center
of mass of the rod which we can imagine
is right at the center of the rod will
translate with some acceleration such
that the vector F is equal to the mass
of the rod times the acceleration of the
center of mass now recall that for a
rigid body this equation will be true
regardless of where on the rod I apply
the force so for example if I draw the
rod again over here and I apply the same
force vector F but I apply it let's say
on the right hand side I'll still have
the same F equals MA all I specify with
F is its magnitude and direction but for
a rigid body no matter where on the body
I apply that force the translation the
the acceleration of the center of mass
will be the same now we know from
experience however that the motion of
the rod is different if I push it at the
center or at the at one end or at the
other end
the point is though that the motion the
overall motion the overall translation
of the object doesn't just involve the
translation in the center of mass but it
also involves some rotation in general
so in fact there is a theorem called
Sholes as theorem
which tells us that the most general
displacement of a rigid body can be
split into the translation of the center
of mass and a rotation about the center
of mass our F equals MA relation tells
us how an applied force affects the
first part the translation of the center
of mass but how does that apply force
affect the rotation of the rigid body
will see that this depends not only on
the magnitude and direction of the force
but also on where the force is applied
okay that's different than the
translation center of mass which only
depends upon what the force is the
rotation about the center of mass
depends both upon the force itself and
where on the object that it's applied in
fact in the next few lessons we'll see
that there's a special equation of
motion for describing rotational motion
that's analogous to Newton's second law
of motion analogous tentacles MA
applying two rotational motion and we
write that relationship this rotational
equation of motion is written as tau
which is a vector is equal to I times
alpha which is a vector so tau is a new
quantity we haven't talked about before
called the torque it's a vector I is the
moment of inertia that we've already
encountered and alpha is the angular
acceleration of the rotation of motion
now Tao is a sort of rotational analog
to the force and it depends upon not
just the force itself but on where the
force is applied computing the torque
Tao depends upon something called a
vector product or cross product it's a
way of multiplying two vectors together
to produce a third vector in that way
it's different than the dot product or
scalar product that we've discussed
earlier where we multiply two vectors
together and get a scalar or a pure
number there's this is a different
operation the vector product or cross
product torque is the first physical
quantity we've encountered but it won't
be the last that involves a cross
product in its definition and so before
giving you a formal definition of torque
will first review the mathematics of
cross products and we'll do that in the
next lesson now the angular acceleration
alpha tells us about how the rotational
motion changes again just like in F
equals MA where we could divide the two
sides of this equation into dynamics and
kinematics kinematics is telling us
about a geometrical description of the
motion of the translational motion and
the dynamics F is telling us about how
the applied forces cause changes in the
motion changes in the kinematics
likewise for rotational motion the
angular acceleration alpha tells us
about the geometry of the rotation of
motion and specifically how the
rotational motion is changing and the
torque is telling us about the
application of forces and how that
causes changes in the rotational motion
so that leaves one other quantity which
is the moment of inertia and I want to
talk about what that means for just a
moment so the term inertia term inertia
and physics represents a resistance to
an applied force it tells us how
difficult it is to change an object's
motion so for example suppose I have two
blocks one of mass
and another that's ten times as massive
so 10 and Newton's second law F equals
MA tells us that if I want to accelerate
the heavier mass to the same rate that I
do with a smaller mass I'll need to
apply a force that's ten times larger so
for translation of motion the mass M
represents the notion of inertia the
resistance to a force it tells us how
much force we have to apply to achieve a
certain change in motion now for
rotational motion that role is played by
the moment of inertia I that tells us
how difficult it is to change the
rotation of an object if I increase the
moment of inertia by a factor of 10 then
I'll need a torque that is 10 times
larger in order to achieve the same
change in rotational motion the same
angular acceleration but recall that our
definition of moment of inertia for some
rigid body is if I break up the rigid
body into a bunch of little pieces and
for each piece I take the product of the
mass of that piece Delta M J times the
perpendicular distance of that piece
from the rotation axis I'll call that R
sub J and if I sum that over the entire
object the entire body that gives me my
moment of inertia well so I'm sorry this
is R squared so it's the the mass of
each element times the distance of the
axis squared Delta M J times are J
squared now I can increase the moment of
inertia by a factor of 10 by increasing
the total mass of the object but you can
see from this equation that I can also
do it with this same mass by changing
the location of the mass if I increase
the ars if I move the mass the same mass
but i but I move it to be farther away
from the rotation axis that also
achieves an increase in the moment of
inertia so what that tells us
the for rotation of motion it's not just
the amount of mass that matters but also
how that mass is distributed okay so in
that sense rotational inertia is
different than translational inertia for
translational motion all that matters is
the mass if I increase the mass by a
factor of 10 then it will become a
factor of 10 more difficult to get that
object to accelerate I need a factor of
10 larger force but with rotational
motion I can increase the notion of
inertia I can make it more difficult to
change the rotation of motion either by
changing the mass by increasing and or
by Inc by making the distribution mass
be further away from the rotation axis
so as an example imagine if you were
rolling a wheel up a hill it's different
if I have a wheel whose mass is
distributed evenly over the whole disk
or if I have all of the mass in the rim
if all of the masses in the rim then
from this equation we see the moment of
inertia is larger for the same amount of
total mass and so it's much more
difficult to roll a wheel up the hill if
all of the mass is in the rim than it is
if the mass is distributed evenly over
the wheel so our rotational equivalent
to Newton's second law is tau equals I
alpha the torque equals the moment of
inertia times the angular acceleration
in the next few lessons we'll see how
torque is defined and we'll derive this
expression for the dynamics of
rotational motion and see how to apply
it